salut à tous les pêcheurs de 13 ans
aujourd'hui je suis tout seul
la pelouse kunter qui roulait encore là
bas lorsque seront mis un bon si on ira
voir il reste des choses je suis moi six
mois va être intéressant ces petites
trouvailles
c'est un mécanisme on dirait un peu le
mécanisme d'une montre avec du cuivre
l'a peut-être une vieille montre de de
poche ça c'est sympa on n'en voit pas
souvent
après ce que j'ai péché aussi pas grand
chose un couteau ça c'est pas mal aussi
est récupérable et or quand on peut
trouver d'autres
[Musique]
à quelque chose puis qui est pic et pic
et deux péniches
art
catherine est
[Musique]
oh c'est quoi ça qu'est ce que c'est que
ce truc c'est marrant bon là je suis
allé faire un tour au pont aux côtés de
chez moi où je suis déjà passé plein de
fois avec le beast et regardez ce que je
vois un caddie tout neuf qui a été sorti
une énorme routière ils ont sorti pas
mal de trucs en durée mais le pire
regardez regardez moi ce qu'ils ont
sorti qu'ils ont laissées sur tout ça
les gars c'est un mécanisme de fusil
avérous et les mecs ils ont sorti sa de
l'eau et dans l'essai je trouve ça
tellement triste ben moi je veux le
récupérer du coup merci les gars ce sera
une pêche à la main qui m'a été donnée à
jamais fait de fusil à verrou donc on va
dire que ça compte mais les gars quand
vous sortez des trucs comme ça pour les
ramener si le souvenir comprends pas que
vous puissiez les c'est ça ou alors vous
saviez pas ce que c'était dommage pour
vous
c'est que ça a c'est une sorte de pont
couche pas de batterie - dans le monde
et ça
genre de ventilateurs on enfin le
climatiseur
chaque helvète en alu d'accord comme
quoi ouais il reste bien des trucs
il reste bien des trucs suspens
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
non je crois que j'ai encore quelque
chose j'ai quelque chose
au cecos a pour ce concert le gras oui
1,8
ah oui le gard
c'est bon ça
ça c'est bon ça sachez
oh oui
je retrouve 1 1
on retrouve les gars
et few minutes slater a je crois je vais
tout doucement
mme joly oblige les lions
ou un autre ça cher
oms a été lesté a été lesté l'égard des
roms ça c'est bon sous toit
pasqua
ça je sais pas trop ce que c'est
mais n'ont rien d'autre à la blague à la
blague
sérieux des papiers
c'est quoi ce papier là
c'est même pas des billes sérieux le
gars tout ça pour cette merde
je sais pas quiconque a laissé en sachet
plastique c'est de merde mais ou alors
peut-être il s'en est servi pour tuer
quelqu un de ces deux trucs très c'est
ce qui attire élément quel travail de
merde je vais quand même les garder
safra souvenir c'est essayer de chercher
ce que c'est aussi celle de merde voilà
je vais juste de remonter première pour
moi un aimant trouverez un aimant avec
mon élément
voilà c'est pas la même puissance mais
ça reste un bon et m'en fais pas pour la
pêche les membres frigo
[Musique]
oh
alors qu'est ce qu'on a devant une aussi
et ici elle est morte
un collier pour ça fait petit pour ses
seins en fallait pour ça c'est pas est
un peu de tout ah oui je les mets de
ramener
ça pèse quelques kilos c'était en plein
milieu je me demande ce que c'est cerci
loin franchement ou plutôt trop de
fautes au maroc
c'est vous c'est fait
pas mal pas mal pas mal
[Musique]
à écrire
et puis c'est quoi ça pas énorme non
on leur dit [ __ ] [ __ ] le faisait
sport non ça va vite une bombe
j'ai passé quand même costaud mais c'est
pas énorme
je sais pas du tout ce que c'est ce
machin
faux d'espoir une fois de plus au
feuillage au salon même c'est ça un
point c'est tout neuf
deux labels bastos super pas du coup on
va continuer à preuve que ce pont
réserve encore de belles surprises
bon bah je vais investiguer mais voilà
sur un beau bébé par une fois bikes nike
peut être qu'à l'aller avec ça qui sait
ouais ça va
non il ya des armes ici
et le lancer de compet d'un corps y aura
au regard des analystes valent au la
valette sa balle ou net
ces minuscules soeur ni moi qu'est ce
que c'est un si petit je vous fais une
différence de taille
nay
moi je vous dirais la fin de la vidéo ce
que c'est comme calibre
oh
s'il ya là dedans vous aimez sachet
pas d'hommage
vidéotron
enfin
un joueur
ça a dû tomber d'une péniche tout ça hop
là toujours servir tout ça
hop voilà donc les deux objets qui
étaient lestés au fond du canal donc je
sais pas vraiment ce que c'est donc s'il
ya des connaisseurs et je me demande ça
valait vraiment le coup de lester ça si
il y avait une raison quelconque
donc on peut savoir que ça s'ouvre donc
bon peut-être qu'ils pouvaient cacher
quelque chose dedans mais bon sinon je
vois pas trop l'intérêt de jeter ces
trucs
voilà si vous avez une idée faites le
moi savoir en commentaire donc tout
d'abord on a une balle de 7,65 brewing
donc celle là elle est marquée 1945
f c'est assez surprenant parce que
normalement il n'y avait pas de
production en france en 1945 forcément
être la guérison arrêter de produire
tout ça donc je pense qu'elle est plutôt
rare
j'ai cherché sur internet j'en ai vue
aucune qui avaient ce marquage voir
intéressant surtout qu'elle est plutôt
bien conservée sympa petite balle de
pistolet on pouvait l'utiliser dans les
pistolets le français comme j'ai pêché
dans une autre vidéo je vous mettrais la
miniature en fin de vidéo de de la pêche
ensuite j'ai trouvé une balle de mother
voilà le fameux fusil allemand bon ça
c'est du classique on en trouve beaucoup
partout avec la tête en acier et la
culasse nettoyait donc que j'ai mis dans
le vinaigre donc celle là elle me paraît
très très vieille aussi parce qu'on voit
que le système est vraiment basique
l'embout comme ça qui est parent on dit
j'ai pas trouvé sur internet donc je
saurais pas dire de quel fuji c'est en
tout cas c'est pas du chassepot c'est
pas du quart 98 pas du mas pas du lobel
donc je sais pas sur un vieux fusil de
chasse
si vous avez des idées sur la présenter
et la provenance exacte de la balle et 2
la culasse bas je suis preneur et on se
retrouve à bientôt pour une autre pêche
ciao